[موسيقى]
عند معبر باب الهوى الحدودي بين سوريا
وتركيا ينتظرون ذويهم من الضحايا الذين
قضوا في الزلزال بمناطق تركيا
واخرون ينتظرون خبرا عن ذويهم المفقودين
اما ابو سامي فجلس وحيدا مفجوعا في اقرباء
كانوا على قيد الحياه انهم تحت الانقاض
يسمع صوت انيمهم حمدو يلا راح نوصل لك يلا
راح نجيب لك مي رح نوصل لك
يلا يا رب يا حمدو
لم يكن اي جثمان من ذويه بين الضحايا
حمده
الانقاض
وعم نحكي معه اموره طلع عايش واموره تمام
اخذوه بالطياره على اضنه
سالنا عن امه واخته واهله قلنا لهن تحت
الانقاض وتوفوا من القهر ما تحمل توفى
مباشر على الخبر حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
وهلق عم نستناهم في المعبر لحتى ناخذه على
الدفن
ينتظر ابو سامي بينما تمر الجنازات كانت
جنازه لجثامين عائله قضت بكاملها
تسلم ذو الضحايا جثامين العائله وذهبوا
الى جبل الزاويه بريفيه الجنوبي
تتوالى صلوات الجنائز منذ اليوم الاول
للزلزال في معظم مناطق شمال غربي سوريا
صلا سبع سنوات طالعين من الضيعه هاي سبع
سنين طبعا في اطفال ما شافت هاي الضيعه
ولا بتعرف هاي الضيعه شو هي
توفوا كمان الله يرحمه يعني استشهد
العدد الاجمالي 12 شهيد سبعه مرعش طبعا
اللي هنا اولاد اخوتي
وعنا خمسه
دفنت عائله ابو محمد في بلدتها ولكن مئات
الضحايا من دمشق وحمصه وحلبه شمال سوريا
بعيدا عن مسقط راسهم ابناء وطن واحد
تفرقوا لاجئين في تركيا
وقدوا في زلزال واحد فرت عائله ابو محمد
من الحرب الى تركيا منذ سنوات ها هم
يعودون اليوم الى سوريا ضحايا تشلوا من
تحت ركام زلزال كهرمان مارش بعد ان لاحقهم
الموت بعيدا في منفعهم
ادهم ابو حسام الجزيره ريف